you know I don't know how it works in
your home country as Halloween a big
deal is you know is it's Halloween
something that's that's celebrated it is
it is it is now when I was a kid it was
less so we would go out we didn't call
it trick-or-treating we called it
guising I don't know well if I sister ya
guys think guising as in we're guys I
don't know I thought your shirt for
disguise oh I go out guising all the
time no one's interested but it's what I
do know we are we are interesting Q very
light to read about you we would go out
and it was it was dressing up it wasn't
so much it didn't have to be horror or
blood or goolie goolie goolie it's it it
was just like being dressing up as
someone else as yes okay so what do
something you do a little poem or a song
or I don't think we ever did a dance but
you when people open the door you would
have to perform a little thing in order
to get there sweetie
or candy as we call them here in America
yeah I love it you call it a sweetie
sweetie sweetie I'm going guising sweet
[Applause]
do you do you get you go ever in
disguise or here in in the United States
do your version yeah out on Halloween it
what have you gone out as I've done I've
done lots of things my most effective
one was Ozzy Osbourne I did Ozzy
Osbourne some years back you were a ski
I was born and how do you how do you do
in Ozzy Osbourne how did you I think I
chose him because I was in the shop
looking for and I found a good wig and
it was a bit like an Aussie wig mm-hmm
and then I had the little glasses yeah
and then because I'm an actor I couldn't
help myself I went deep into be careful
what I say but I went quite deep into
character yeah and I would I was walking
around with my kids and Brent Brent
would you know guising guys somebody
came up to my mate robber and they went
we didn't know he lived here yeah and
they thought I was Ozzie Ozzie just I
think kind of forget for
[Applause]